Дональд Трамп звинуватив Україну у спробі перешкодити його обранню на посаду президента США.
Про це Трамп написав у соціальній мережі Twitter. Ймовірно йдеться про те,
що Київ нібито допомагав його екс-опонентці Гілларі Клінтон зібрати компромат на оточення Трампа.
Історію про контакт українців з демократичною партією Гілларі Клінтон під час виборів ще у січні
цього року опублікувало впливове американське видання Politico. За даними видання, американка
українського походження Александра Чалупа працювала на штаб Гілларі Клінтон і звернула увагу на зв'язки тодішнього керівника
передвиборчого штабу Трампа Пола Манафорта з екс-президентом України Віктором Януковичем.
Як пише Politico, Чалупа нібито зверталась до українського посольства у США по інформацію про Пола Манафорта.
Ймовірно саме цей факт Дональд Трамп намагається прирівняти до скандалу про зв'язки його штабу з Росією.
Мовляв опоненти діяли так само. Але низка американських видань вважає таке порівняння недоцільним.
По-перше, втручання Росії у вибори США було санкціоноване на рівні Кремля. Американські спецслужби виявили, що президент Росії Путін
ініціював незаконні хакерські атаки і викрадення інформації з метою втрутитися у вибори США та підірвати демократичну систему,
пише видання The Washington Post. І додає - свідчень про санкціоновані керівництвом України спроби вплинути на вибори немає.
По-друге, способи отримання компрометуючої інформації - різні. Як пише видання Politfact, Кремль збирав інформацію про Клінтон у незаконний спосіб.
А саме, американська розвідка виявила, що Путін наказав хакерам зламати комп'ютерні системи американських політичних організацій.
Натомість Александра Чалупа проводила розслідування щодо Манафорта самостійно, а не під керівництвом Демократичної партії.
А відомості про виплати Манафорту в книзі чорної бухгалтерії Партії регіонів були оприлюднені депутатом Сергієм Лещенком,
як частина розслідування в Україні. Тобто вони не були отримані незаконно.
По-третє, нема доказів того, що члени штабу передвиборчої кампанії Клінтон контактували з українським урядом.
Натомість є задокументовані докази того, що син Трампа, його зять та екс-керівник виборчої кампанії зустрічалися з російською адвокаткою
і намагалися отримати компромат на Клінтон від російського уряду, стверджує видання The New York Times.
Окрім того сама зустріч Александри Чалупи з українськими дипломатами, якщо вона і мала місце, не є незаконною.
Прямих доказів того, що українська влада втручалась у виборчий процес у США - немає. Збір інформації Александрою Чалупою про Манафорта
шляхом звернення до українського посольства не можна порівнювати із хакерськими атаками Кремля на опонентів Трампа під час виборчої кампанії.
На думку оглядачів, Дональд Трамп звинуватив Україну у втручанні у вибори США,
щоб відвернути увагу суспільства від низки скандалів його штабу щодо зв'язків з Кремлем.